[Music]
welcome all right and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 73 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm very
excited about our special guest so we're
gonna get right into it I would
introduce a Lord when my opinion is one
of the most positive and refreshing
members in our entire gaming community
although Xbox is his preferred console
this Lord is a true multi-platform gamer
is extremely honest with his console
opinions and ultimately has to oh gee
arcade resume to prove it introducing
the host of breakfast with bowl a
panelist on the crossfire podcast and
the creator of the double-barrel gaming
youtube channel the long arm of the law
and the lord who correctly recognizes
resident evil 2 as the goat of the
series New York City's finest making his
debut into the realm of the Lord's mommy
Lord boomstick Excel how you doing sir
let me just say something right off the
bat I have to take some pointers from
you bro because that was one hell of an
opening I'm getting goose bumps and I
should game this myself MVP for having
like thinking twos the go what does that
make me for thinking Forza go you can't
you can listen you can't front on for
the first first resident the first for
Resident Evil games you know you throw
Veronica okay I'll give people this for
is the reason that were the the
franchise went in the direction it did
is that is correct yeah but just because
for ruin the franchise doesn't mean for
was a bad guy
we go hit that subject trust me first
and foremost guys I have been really a
chomping at the bit to get on the show
and we've talked privately I'm so
honored to be here I mean I've listened
to you guys show numerous times you know
what what our shows do is they talk
about gaming but there is a passion in
the voice that is something that could
not be faked right this isn't a fake
news episode this is real gamers talking
about real news and getting excited and
sometimes depressed on things that
happen you know when your favorite
company gets an L you know it's it's
it's you know it's like your favorite
ball team regardless of what kind
whether it be bball whether it be
absolutely it when your team gets it now
you get the press that Monday comes
around and you can't wait for the next
Sunday because you have to wipe away
that L is very much the same thing yes
something bad and you're like my god
Phil what happened I look at Sony you
look at Nintendo you know and you and
you get the press because you want
everyone to wins ok and I really mean
this when I say this when these
companies win you win absolutely preach
that's them it's the Lord's work being
taught right now I'm saying because
you're the game or you're the one that's
supporting the console or all three
consoles so when a good game comes out
or a good decision comes out you're the
winner at the end of the day so again
I'm really excited to be here I cannot
wait to get into these topics
you already know much appreciate it Lord
boomstick your Lord in your room so it's
only right we showed you the proper
respect here at the round table and
definitely a lot of our thoughts of
lines that we're gonna get at these
topics have some fun but of course we
have the Four Horsemen of gaming those
usual suspects at the round table
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
house of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir I'm doing
pretty good you know it's nice to be
here nice to be on the
lowers a day on ILP definitely has some
good topics absolutely Matt good to see
hey be honest with their own you know
the topics are what if one of them
topics I got from you
they're fables and we go get that way go
papa you go get that going no glad you
made him I know you had a rough week and
uh everyone try to send their love and
support to my boy Lord haddock I'm so
happy he came through and uh like I said
we go have some fun and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
players selfish experience and also the
sastra Thomas mr. Flamm profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon of the iron
bank madman
Lord sovereign how you doing sir I'm
doing all right man you know I might
have to be in therapy with you guys
weekend but UFC picked up my Spurs oh I
don't remember seeing any fight talk
last night King what happened I will
address this one is my turn look at the
me respecting the Lord's ability to talk
intros let's go through the intros and
then we'll come back and no doubt and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer mm the Lord of
combat sports who's a man of his
convictions that means nothing less than
that premium experience and is to get
money gamer Oh beloved Lord King how you
doing sir I'm doing incredible today and
I gotta say I'm doing incredible today
because my boy addict showed up I
thought he wasn't gonna be here I was
really depressed because there's a topic
I want some amends to go in on with
I'm feeling it's switch really but but
this is this is the funny part I had a
lot of questions for combat all right
because it was fight yesterday and you
know to get me to feel motivated and
move to do a combat talk has to be
something that is worthy of me taking my
time out and Express and predict and see
and document and do detail our coverage
of the fight um I didn't see that this
weekend you have surgery Koval off
versus player one um you had Andre Berto
versus definite Alexander now and Andre
Berto versus Devon Alexander you had a
guy whose body who broke down on him and
Andre Berto over he has too many
surgeries the boy got too fat on his own
success and he lost his hunger and he
quits in the ring that's not a dog that
I can back in a fight alright and Devon
Alexander was addicted to opioids all
right so he has a weak Constitution so I
can't trust him going into the ring so
you have two potential ELLs walking but
I say this I say this to say if I had to
give a prediction of the fight I would
definitely took Berto for the simple
fact that being that some person was on
opioids that means he doesn't reflect
his body that means he doesn't respect
his temple and I believed that he would
fatigue out and get stopped later on he
didn't get stopped they went to a
decision Bertil one guarana whatever
Sergey Kovalev do not like Sergey
Kovalev
at all I do not like him as a person do
I know him personally no but what he has
exhibited outside the ring and what he
has done to his camp mainly the
minorities that was in his camp that got
him to his position he turned on them he
made references that was racist
so allegedly he's a racist right
allegedly um I don't want
too strong this man lost our Andre Ward
and never gave him the respect never
reflected on his loss and why he lost
and how he lost so if you never reflect
on what went wrong with you you are
doomed to make that same mistake that's
right it will always come back to your
doorstep greater than the last time it
left this time your man got knocked out
don't cold it was a destruction sent
from the gods the humble a man put him
in the set of bushes and so surgeon joy
your time in the bushes I did not feel
that people were worthy for fight talk
but being that my inbox went crazy
yesterday I had at least 50 DMS by
individual shoutout to Requin yo and
shout-out to cat daddy fast acts in the
chat man salute Lord like thanks for
that cold for you know putting it in the
chat much appreciated man is a huge
supporter we see them live thank you so
much bro I did not want to take up any
time of this to be honest with you guys
but being that you requested it and
being a sovereign just got good know
that it was UFC fights I get it we get
it to that we pay the bills if they
would get it
so of course actually we have the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi blow a Cognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the IOP now telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hit so lord
solved you want to jump in now or you
want to kick their bill yes it's that
time to say to salute and bend the knee
to all of our patreon subscribers thank
you so much guys you guys really the
outpouring from the beginning of this
has been great and patreon and
boy who's here every Sunday afternoon
with us we've always said this is
amazing that you guys take time out of
your Sunday's to come chill out with us
and listen to our foolishness every
Sunday so let's get into the shoutouts
to our patreon subscribers so let's
start off with Lord whisky himself the
Lord of lowly all the whiskies all the
whisky he earned that me many three
[Laughter]
words the PlayStation brand it's my
doing
followed by Lord Michael Lugo thank you
in the chat every Sunday with us
wallah bill himself Lord well we gonna
talk about him we get to the ball oh
yeah followed by Lord irrelevant native
thank you sir yes appreciate it brother
love no other sport Lord Spoonman fellow
Lord Jim Hardin I see them tweets we
just talked about him Lord cat daddy fat
stags yes sir ah very rare we get him
live on the show we really appreciate it
mm-hmm another Lord of combat sports
legit Fonzarelli him stream team maestro
Lord smelled oh yeah check his stream
out had a good one he's doing it he's
doing over cook with the wife it was fun
follow my lord snail killer himself
Diego Padre of the chat little bit
Diablo mission at the time the time is
crazy but Oh Lord death singer thank you
so much
Babji kings public brethren
and last but absolutely not least Lord
optimist code
y'all have you on soon brother have you
won support thank you thank you thank
you
so now let's get into these giveaways
right let's start off with our $10 gift
card giveaway so I have daddy
congratulations brother
you just made a DM so we'll take care
that now our t-shirt giveaway is the big
one is the one they love that Lord swag
swag
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a just one daddy has one like I
think he's won every single
[Laughter]
we're ready to go you guys set me in the
DM z-- and we'll take care of these
co-hosted always that one second hold on
I want y'all to go to that little thumbs
up button anyone who thinks car wars
gonna have so spider-man hit that like
boy you did come back last two fights
I just watched last two from you
fantastic um man Henry cejudo new
champion be DJ very close razor close I
thought it could I did enough but I
usually no type of fights goes to the
champion so surprised because of that
yeah I was surprised it almost like he
didn't get that [ __ ]
yeah he was he had secured two takedowns
he's just a bigger stream he's really
too big for that division let's keep it
real like he he's a big cuts a lot of
weight to go down today which is why him
calling out teased a it was interesting
yeah got a handle his business with um
Dominick Cruz so we're getting to that
obviously TJ versus call it a big one
I'm a huge Cody fan but man he got
exposed he got exposed he for being just
- he hasn't involved he hasn't involved
and the problem is the big right hand I
mean literally soft he D TJ we played
the way he knocked him out the first
time when this swinging and he's doing
short shots and beating him to the punch
it is turned so versatile man two kicks
and he you almost he's like a villain
right because of the ring smiling
but you can't hate him because he's so
confident so it looks like the move from
alpha Mecca helped him better than Kohli
and I'm Safa called because right now he
may be a broken guy like those guys that
lose fights like that that were once
dominate and undefeated sometimes they
don't get that confidence back so is the
measure
I think Cody Cody is this I think he
they this is what TJ realized right he
realized that he was fighting in an echo
chamber where he wasn't going to improve
beyond a certain point yes that's been
alpha males problems that's the problem
yeah they don't tighten it then they
peek out and they don't evolve beyond
that yeah cody has some physical
attributes over TJ this used to his
advantage and he's faster than TJ mm-hmm
he has more length than TJ well for the
most part I think does have a shorter
recent TJ but the thing when Cody is I
think he still went into this fight
despite what he said he went into this
fight fighting with his emotion emotion
yes good this is not to see him get the
same sniper that I saw take apart
Dominick Cruz right he was gonna be the
future he hurt TJ a little bit he worked
to crazy excited yeah it wasn't that
hurt and he got bite him yeah and he
would he was not willing just to beat
him he wanted to he wants to it yeah
he's I'm not I'm screwed on these two
emotion and that's when I when I saw
just to finish this and we go along but
like when I saw him weighing just when
he first clip TJ and weighing all wide
and literally it felt like TJ was doing
the shorter shots and just spamming the
button like it was a video and he was
funny almost three combinations in a row
and Cory made no adjustments so that's
what I knew the kid is too low too
emotional he's got physical gifts he has
to evolve he may have to leave alpha
male but I just think he if he could
have he could have fought better but he
just he's too emotional exciting yeah
cuz we would afford him to wait for
Dominic
yeah can't yes he was in his own man
absolutely so shout UFC last night it
was fantastic so let's get finally into
the show and our guest so actually
before we get into what we're playing
the Lord's we're gonna start off with
Lord boom his video game system history
for over 40 years he's joining in to the
podcast room with the crossfire podcast
and Lord much and finally his
inspiration to get started as a new
content creator so Lord boom let's start
from the beginning what were like some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming
well my first video game system that I
had it was 1978 the Atari 2600 my dad my
dad brought it home oh man
yeah this is the old man room I'm gonna
bring back something that a lot of these
young yeah check this out I I was
sitting with my brother at my grandma's
house and we saw in the Sears catalog
remember there was no internet back in
the second I saw the Atari 2600 and it
had pac-man and Missile Command and
space invaders so I had pointed it out
and my mom was like my dad listen we got
to get this for the you know for the
kids because you know they do the right
thing by us to do their chores right
they say their prayers so mm-hmm
they my dad came home with it one day I
brought home the Atari 2600 you know
with the paddles you know those things
are yeah and the two controllers and we
played combat we played Missile Command
we played space invaders and pac-man and
you know again back in the days there
were no colors in this game ah but a
trick was if you turned all the lights
off in the house and you kind of mess
with the color you got the ghosts to
have color one button stick and you know
what dude um I have been fortunate in
innocent my parents were
you know my mom never worked because my
dad was the breadwinner and he was a
blue-collar dude we were not rich we
were we weren't even middle-class to be
quite honest I'm not a human shame to
say it because you know you got to start
somewhere and you got to start at the
bottom and work your way up and I am
fortunate to say that video games
grabbed me in a way that nothing else
did I mean when I was a kid my favorite
thing was GI Joes right I got that was a
little bit comfortable grip you know
Thundercats
transformers man talking all the 80s
stuff right so you know I only got five
hours a week for allowance and that
wasn't enough so you know I wanted games
and you know I wanted to you know I
wanted the ColecoVision and I wanted the
the Vectrex and I wanted you know the
and stuff like that you know the the NES
and the way I did is I started
delivering the post and penny savers to
kind of you know make up that little
extra money so hustling you know and I
had two three jobs at a time even as a
kid you know because video games was my
thing and it turns out that 40 years
later video games are still my thing and
you know III I've been fortunate enough
to say that I've owned every console in
the US this is Kingdom you're in king
level now even some of the most obscure
things Virtual Boy Neo Geo car Neo Geo
CD you know it's and again my family you
know we didn't have a lot of money but I
had a drive that I still have to this
day that you know if you want something
you got to work for it I don't know if
that you know that that's a definite
term that you don't really that's kind
of lost with this generation and I'm not
insulting anyone buddy not everyone has
the drive facts and what drove me and oh
no I a lot of people whether you notice
or not I was in New York City police
officer for 21 years
New York City's finest in a building I
grew up in the projects
that's a housing development because
some people that don't know what that is
I've talked talked that New York so
that's we carefully and
I was fortunate enough to go back to my
same community as a police officer and
for 17 out of those 21 years I worked
with the youth and it was probably the
best career I could have ever asked for
because I was in the neighborhood that I
used to run around in and I was hanging
out with some of the young and young and
upcoming cats here and him in the
direction of you don't have to be bad to
be cruel that's grand I went back to the
school I graduated Columbus high school
and I was the Columbus Wow and I
graduate I graduated there in 89 and
went back in 97 as the school cop and I
was there as a youth officer and I gotta
tell you guys you know I know that the
press makes it out for you know guys to
be you know devils and you know what
everyone is not a good guy because if we
have a shield and a gun I'm gonna tell
you that right now and I came across a
funny plenty of people that well I was
ashamed to cool you know you know
comrades if you will but I came across a
hell of a lot of people with the same
story that means started with nothing
started poor and then made a name for
themselves and actually took wearing
that that shield with respect and honor
which is what I did every day we
listened we commended and like first of
all I'm glad I'm glad you said what you
said because that's very very important
you know and and also being able to give
back to your own neighborhood way that
words don't even put out there dude yeah
absolutely
and actually I just want to go back one
second which again history on one things
I know we had your repertoire is
expansive so I got asked about did you
you said you had everything so I'm I'm
assuming yes did you had Coleco and I
told you feel alone Akali because that
was my first system that was my dad gave
that to me that was the first kind of
gaming system I ever touched and that's
how am I like a affection for gaming
started like what was your any memories
with Kali Gordo
yeah there were two big ones with that
one first and foremost Donkey Kong was
arcade like when I first saw it now I'm
gonna be honest with you the controllers
with the telephones but with the tip
i'ma tell you this if you guys remember
this now when rocky came out for that
console Oh remember yes they had those
controls that look like boxing gloves
that you had it had the red knob yes yes
yeah because I bought day they had yeah
that was when they kind of like I would
say like right around like right after
Adam because I believe that Coleco then
they had like the atom with the cleat
was like a PC Kalika oh and then I
remember they came out with the new car
I had it looked like a boxing glove it
was black it had a red knob on top it
had the numbers smaller numbers oh you
talking that talk yeah and I remember I
remember playing rocky and you know you
watch the movie as a kid and you play in
the game you think rocky you know you're
running around the house this big boxing
glove thing on you I'm gonna tell my
mama but I'm gonna punch my brother with
it a lot of people don't understand that
was probably my all-time favorite young
childhood system it was like probably
besides the table top systems ahead like
Donkey Kong pac-man or something like
that which was you know Popeye I would
have Popeye was amazing to me but that
was the first like little portable
system like I go to my friend's house
and I can take it with me and I can play
asteroids arcade perfect asteroids and
his house Oh Oh what was it they had lit
which is a football game and what was a
lot of people don't know some people say
what vetrix what it was okay well really
what it was it was his own contained TV
screen and the controller used to throw
them into it and the wire you should
just plug into the wall so you could
carry it I mean listen as a kid it's a
little heavy I ain't gonna front
what made this thing very very different
is that it was in color and you had to
put plastic I believe screams yes you
get the color of gas to make it color
and it worked because each game came
with the good the cartridge which again
people need to have that is cartridges
wooden talking about and what's crazy is
back in those days because it was it was
the time where everyone is actually
right at the time when video game
imploded where in 1983 the video game
industry died and this came out right
before that and a cigarette company made
a game I still have it it's worth about
$800 it's called clean sweep and it's a
big man and it was made by a seeker I
think it was a cigar company because
they wanted to kind of get in on the
video game craze um let me tell you I
mean the one thing I will say about
being an older game I mean no one wants
to get old but I am gonna say that being
having an ideology of where we came from
yes so where we are now is it's like
magic when gaming is like magic and what
you see on the screens now you got to
remember there were some young cats
starting with the ps4 so they don't
understand what dot graphics and I said
daddy preach to him let him learn you
remember circus Atari with the panel
fell the guy made that crunching a clunk
like guy died again like I said it learn
your videogame history before you get on
social media you start spitting some
nonsense because we all again if you
started in the ps4 era I'm not gonna say
I don't feel bad for you because I kind
of do um you know well then these indie
games come out and they're like that's
just crap look at the graphics most rap
while he says quickly
yeah I mean so like I said it's it's
really interesting to see where we are
now I'm I'm I love gaming as much as any
other hobby I've ever done I've stayed
strong with it 40 years I mean before
becoming an you know New York City
police officer my career at the time cuz
I always wanted since I was a kid I was
playing with my GI Joes I wanted to be a
good guy that was my thing but before
then I wanted in in in video games and I
just I never wanted to make them because
I feel it would ruin it for me so I
worked for phone call and that was a
manager of my own Central Avenue in
Yonkers Ohio knew Rocksteady top yeah so
it's uh you know it was like I said I
never got away from it I used to be a
big importer penguin village no but I
used to go to his place in Queens where
the guy's name was it was a spot on st.
Mark's on by the cube I think about you
I think you bet me King I lost the bet
to you stupidly because they'd last to
the store was a big queue he said I bet
you are and I said this is real quick
this is really quickly the best the best
gotcha story we walk in and I seen a bum
pushing it and Cognito was you're
talking to me so I'm looking at the bum
pushed it and I'm like yo cut yeah [ __ ]
I can push that on the square
you're the square is crazy ginormous
push that so I go over to place on
Linden Boulevard in Queens
okay okay they had the two statute two
spots one around each corner and if you
walked a little up there was a little
bizarre there that you know you know
back in the days they used to get the
import games in way before I mean I had
a Playstation one almost you know yeah
like a chain of them now that was like
when his satellite so we know what
you're talking about cuz that we had we
had the plug
we had the younger generation the chat
like put it like this if PlayStation 4
came out whenever it released how it
will work is we would get the Japanese
import maybe six months oh we gotta have
Playstation whatever that put the
PlayStation 1 placement to before it
released in America and a lot of the
control is pretty much the same in some
games you could even change the the
translation in UI and starting game so
it wasn't the house we got to play like
shenlin all that stuff before hey like
it was a pattern that every time you
know the famous cook the Japanese one
and a lot of times there was no arm even
with correct me if I'm wrong can a lot
of the systems
it was region-free if you had to dance
yeah you could just hold onto it so it
was just a really cool time and if you
love gaming you hunted it down they
weren't in the internet you know it
wasn't big for gaming like that you
waited for your game Pro
interview yes right your game Pro you're
done got your news and a lot of people
understand it so you have to really have
a passion in 73 yes and watch the
videotape this is we have to wait for it
to come in the mail and when we got it
we see all those top loading and put it
in
if your joint was broke you put books on
top forget man I wind up I don't know if
you guys remember this place Dragons Den
yes first guy Jerry used to own the
store I'll never get used to Soto damn
III tasted $30 put on $15 a piece
together went battle gear solid for the
first time when he went him and the
chick or firing the gun back and I was
like this is it please what it's all
about what it's about but questions and
specific generations that I don't hear
about I want to know what we're
obviously if you had I mean what you
remember from one was the 8-bit era with
Master System the second I want to know
about all the what's called really was
16-bit still kind of armed with turbo
graphics 16 okay and then the other one
was 32-bit did you go 3do did you go
Jaguar because that was kind of in the
middle it was first of all I just want
to do a quick Jaguar story funny because
okay just imagine this for a second now
now back in the days I worked in a
prison that was in in the Bronx and you
know we didn't have we didn't have
internet there was no way to the only
way you found that if the game was
coming and she kept calling and I was
that guy so I had coal dragons then and
I'm like hey listen I'm gonna see if
aliens vs. predator is in yeah we got it
in oh my god could you please hold a
copy all right well we closed go yeah
now I was at a detail now what that
basically means is you know I was
working I was in uniform and I go over
to my sergeant I'm like you know I got a
question because I was new I'm like can
I leave aliens vs. predator just came to
totally I sure did I salute and he
looked at me and he said boy you better
get back on your post if you want
you if you want a job tomorrow I've
walked away with my tail between my legs
I really want this game released from
this detail now from Pelham Parkway John
Kerr talked me okay now back then you
know I kind of drove a little bit of a
souped-up car oh I had I had a Chevy
Super Sport okay eight cylinder under
the hood for a foot in here she no joke
let's go
I made it to Yonkers in nine minutes
that was taken and I got my game and
don't you know that we got called in
sick turbo graphics and regards to three
do you know remember you gotta remember
three do that was a that was a $600
system when that joint came out that was
big bucks but I had it I bought it I
played the hell out of Kasumi ninja I'm
really taking it back to the church or
Bo graphics I had that um but what a lot
of people don't remember is still to
this day the best Castlevania ever
released Dracula you know what don't you
know I still have that damn card moorage
I almost wish I had my turbo graphx is
16 Express best handheld ever picture
perfect eight batteries in and eight
batteries came out one hour later
[Laughter]
when you're going back and forth to
RadioShack to buy batteries with charges
you know you guys are talking about
Castlevania a lot like my favorite
Castlevania is actually what everyone
hates but really which one I really
really enjoy curse the darkness light
really enjoy 6401 I don't remember what
it was on but it had the innocent Devils
in it you had already don't feel like
that on the same way like I'm not I'm I
do not pretend to be a Castlevania
hardcore person my favorite button a lot
of people hate is actually 64 because I
was just so impressed me to rotate that
there's nothing like seen a skeleton on
a motorcycle 7 I think the reason I
enjoyed that game so much is because it
was out of the norm for a Castlevania
game you didn't have that all you know
Dracula's back now I'm a descendant of a
descendant of a descended or the last
loser that killed him it was like
Dracula is dead I was a juror in his
army and now people tried to get him
back and I don't want him back so I'm
gonna fight my own peoples to make sure
he don't come back and what's funny is
the innocent Devils they were Dracula's
powers so you were literally using his
own abilities against I guess to be a
man this is this is great history man
love your videogame system history and
very kooky what you mentioned was like I
said connecting it to you being in law
enforcement because back then like you
said la boum like it wasn't really cool
to be a gamer back in the day like you
guys don't have any idea how bad I had
that that priest I could all
like like he was a giant baby let me
tell you got to remember so yeah I'm a
kid I got on when I was 22 when I was a
young kid full of piss and vinegar right
cool back in the days that's how they
treated you man they treated you like
dirt because you know you don't know
whether you were a rat or whatever and
they don't like you because we know we
don't know what we're doing and you know
are things all just hanging out swinging
around all over you know I remember
saying when I took my vacation like a
boom with you you know where you going
on your vacation I'm not going anywhere
I'm playing Resident Evil to vacation
for Resident Evil 2 and don't you know
that they turned my locker around they
put some bids on let me tell you
something it had been easier come on see
and I was a gay man being a video game
player and what's more crazy than that
nowadays is so mainstream reading they
don't just come out and you know what if
you aren't playing games you are the
weirdo the originator in that prison I
get no I get no credit for it when we
grew up we change the narrative yes
that's the whole thing like this is why
our movies are this is why transformers
it's good this why Joe is good here's
what I'm gonna make a Thundercats this
is why all those Marvel movies is good
we grew up we are in control right now
so the fact that we are in control these
systems you know that guy that did a
motion engine for that PlayStation
probably had an Atari 2600 and was sick
to his stomach with those graphics not
on my watch yeah a lot of those cuz I
remember you know when my generation
takes their oh my god
generation generation majority these
games right no I do not know that but I
do know that we are in charge of you so
pretty much you don't get the podcast
YouTube journey so obviously will let
you to cross why I would lower mooch in
those guys and then branching out to
your own channel with a double-barrel
gaming it was a whim really just just a
complete whim I I used to be the guy the
the the media guy right i had
subscriptions to IGN and Giant Bomb and
get spot all these other things and then
something happened in 2013 the xbox came
out and the media went from reporting it
to opinion aiding it yes and I I you
know I started to see that the the Xbox
platform which was my favorite platform
wouldn't became the whipping boy and for
a lot of good reasons I miss you take
nothing away from Microsoft you can't is
what am i there there in the daran daran
third place for a reason and you know I
started to see that the media wasn't
reporting the news that I wanted so I
heard from several people and crazy
enough my nephew 9 my godchild 10
YouTube YouTube YouTube and like what is
this YouTube thing that everyone eats
for I was the old man Michael YouTube so
I started by typed in video games and a
whole bunch of sites came out and the
first one that popped up was was
crossfire so let me take a look so I
started listening to that and I'm like
okay there's some guys I don't really
care for
some guys I do like mooch specifically
is responsible for where I'm at and I
give him all the credit for that because
I love old I gay i DM him and I said hey
listen any chance that you have you know
community members on your show and he
said yeah it's something that we do
would you like to come on
and in June 27 June 2017 I got my shot
and I came on and I was nervous and
listen to me you know III I'm speaking
the same way I was speaking there but I
didn't have as much confidence behind
the mic because I obviously I'm no
mm-hmm the podcast scenario text on the
building yes it certainly does and you
said this dude laboum has just earned a
new sub with the segment before for the
last six hours did it does being a good
guy piss off my shot and then the next
week he kind of asked me do you want to
do it again and as in then then then two
weeks later he said hey we're getting a
lot of good feedback people like the way
you speak they say you have that
old-time radio voice which which I I
hate my voice I just want you to know
that I hate it what other people like
yeah yeah it's like an old-time without
fire I was like yeah I like this dude
he's definitely passionate and um you
you definitely resonate what a
generation also doesn't have a voice now
like I mean they're running things we're
called oh jeez know what I'm saying and
you gotta remember you know I remember
coming back I remember being on coming
on to the department I'm like look at
all these old dinosaurs
don't you know that when I was getting
ready to get out I had kids calling me
old dinosaur this smile somebody you
know what you are right for that kid
because I said the same thing about the
other Oh Dino it's a cycle but he gave
me my shots I did um you know I did I
did a few episodes and then it became a
regular and then mail from Korpi
carriages and consuls asked me on as a
guest I came on once and she got an
outpour of like subs and messages so she
asked me to be a regular so I did that
and then after doing it for a few months
I make you know I'm really enjoying this
nice but I kind of want to do my own
thing because I wanted to exactly what
you said I wanted I want to talk about
what we did back in the days but still
be relevant which is why I have two live
shows the Friday one is current news and
and really the the whole on ideology
behind the Friday show wasn't just for
me
so I try to get as many new guests on as
I can because I want to promote people
the same way I was promoted so I it's my
way of giving back and push okay
reach and and the Tuesday show which is
the booms pop up podcast it varies in
subjects but like for instance this
week's show is going to be 2007 a year
in gaming the greatest year aiming oh
you know and we're gonna we're gonna
talk about all the tiles that came out
because that is still revered as one of
the best years in gaming history all
three systems absolutely and also we're
gonna you know so I like talking about
the old stuff and then you know I just
really liked the responsibility of doing
my own work doing my own research doing
my own show but at the same time
promoting others that that's really what
it came down to
well we appreciate what you're doing man
very very positive stuff in the
community got it that strap try to get a
chance when I can because actually I
work nights so when I come in the
morning I actually could catch breakfast
with boom because I'm all for it back
hello yeah I'm a really good show you
had I believe you had a box and a couple
of the guys yes that I know yeah oh just
like wow that was cool to see great time
it's good stuff much respect there so
we're gonna ask this or actually uh we
ask this to every guest so uh you know
basically Lord boom what should top five
games or franchises of all time well
number that's it that's actually super
easy to be completely on rez resident to
number one resident three number two
best characters castlevania sympathy of
the night number three goes strong
playstation title Final Fantasy seven
which I beat by the way in Japanese the
first time on my import and we beat it
again in when the import you was you
start to figure out all those games it's
okay to you don't even go to because I
actually told somebody go watch the
video on how to get the whisper and then
come back to me so let me to be finicky
we've always had nice to call it a steak
a hotline oh my god they used to send me
a packet worth of like tips and tricks
my mom hello Sega sending you like any
trips
you know cool the Nintendo operator you
could cost your father and your mama $20
per cool how do I do it
do it all I'm saying is I beat all the
Final Fantasies move out pass it's not
my fault you wanted to damage yourself
like that he's talking talk and we are
all bonding with him and you are alien
in this situation would you do that I
want the easy way no no listen to me
listen to me we didn't know magic spells
was there because the first time I
tripped up nights of the round I was
like you said um yeah yeah yeah 7 was 2
p.m. and my fifth one ninja gayden black
which I which I beat on hard difficult
did you be that on
[Laughter]
listen yo yo gaming history starts at a
cue please sit down and be like I guess
if you I want you in this segment to
understand that he has to make yourself
relevant right now know right now by
injecting yourself into this situation
did you beat the spire yo and your
destiny versus the young young bucks so
that's cool so lord I just want to get
into prophecy we know you know the ad
love affair for Evil Dead is that all
based your name walk from evil the
horror games like there's that chick
well horror games you know it's not just
so it's not the my favorite genre you
know I like the open world
action-adventure kind of a games but the
whole mr. boomstick XL definitely comes
from Evil Dead me my
others probably favorite film of all
time and you know again it's can't be
horror you know what I'm saying but it
was it was fun it was fun hard you know
I'm saying and and and you know like I
said it's it's it's what's the you know
the double-barrel gaming and mr.
boomstick it came from though that those
names a derivative of the Evil Dead
franchise I see it it had to give the
shell that's like I do what he's doing
that's appreciate that that was though
absolutely this obviously fantastic
history games we got a lot stuff to get
into so on we're gonna move on so
quickly on what all the Lords playing
right now so start with what what are
you playing right now I'm playing but
yeah you know when the summer comes
around we all all of us have backlogs of
shame and you know I've been I've been
trying to tell you know I'm trying to
hit that three hundred thousand game a
score I'm just short of just fifty
thousand short of hitting that and I
don't know if I'm gonna hit it by the
end of the year but I've been chopping
down the the backlog and kind of like
getting at these uh these telltale games
that I go get those thousand point games
to yeah so III never you know III know
what the ending is because I receive
it's a game as old as hell but I'm
playing a through I just I just split I
just beat Michonne the three-part series
which was fantastic you know your fan of
the of the Walking Dead you get to see
her backs were kids that's yes
that was deep I did like that long and
I'm playing through Walking Dead Season
one I'm really enjoying it I started it
I think like two or three times on the
360 in the ps3 but I never never got
around to like episode two I'm I just
started episode three and last a couple
like last weekend and the week prior I
be guardians the galaxy a bit the Batman
season two nice points with those like
it quick you know I wasn't doing it just
for the points it was a shame that I
never got around to these games because
they don't take that long they don't you
know what I'm saying and we are in a
lull and it's not going to ramp up until
like you know the
you know the middle part of September
you got to knock them out now you know
you have your two already quite a man
you know definitely those are big ones
and obviously you know you got your you
know a coral duty black ops is a big
pass for me because that's a multiplayer
yeah so I'm trying to chop down some of
this you know backlog of shame and
moving along oh good lord
addict man what do you blame recently
I'm about to start playing dead space
probably here today I've been playing a
little bit of Destiny and I've been
playing a lot of persona 5 and that's
cool my box was very happy to hear this
yeah I've been uh about to finish with
the second palace okay cool so just said
pretty much pretty much that's what I'm
taking up a lot of your time yeah I've
been up moving and stuff so I played a
whole lot but I played persona 5 for
about an hour and a half this morning
oh right so the podcast which I picked
up the Mega Man Legacy Collection the
Mega Man X Legacy Collection the first
part you see uh the first three Megaman
X Games which are the best ones out of
the bunch so I touched that a little bit
i pre-ordered dead cells on the switch
that game came out in early access on PC
last year I didn't even know you can
pre-order stuff on the switch I'm gonna
be real with you so I got that
pre-ordered for next week that is like a
Metroidvania slash road roguelike they
got a lot of positive buzz when it went
into early access last year so it's 1.0
um as of Tuesday and that's for the PC
ps4 I believe I don't know if it's
coming to Xbox immediately and switch so
it'll be the officially out no no and
then what else and you won't believe me
what I was what I was quietly on the
Xbox
trying to finish cursive oh sorry
offline profile Illuminati don't you
guys don't care about playing story
stuff with like Tony
I'm gonna just right now I'm gonna just
we just did something that I really
can't understand I'm going to address
that when it's my like I don't like
playing the story stuff because I don't
like doing it as soon as I'm done with
curse of Osiris you will see me online I
want to play war mine I wanna I want to
get my numbers up selfish single-player
experience if I wonder what once in a
while it would be nice to get in this
light and see you all on once once
that's done you will see me online
online we have a seat quiet it's been
quite some time I prompt get a boogie
put what are your first hormone a
shout-out to my Lord brought my brethren
J pons really happy born day bro in the
realm an absolutely man that's that's
royalty in the chat right now Lord King
what you been playing them ok well that
should never be questioned this week of
solstice of heroes let me tell you
something I have two characters that are
purple I'm working on my third character
to get him the purple now by me speaking
that speak right there only if you're
playing socials of heroes will you
understand what I'm talking about and
how difficult and hard that situation of
a serious part of a grind that is now I
would like to give a shout out to the
clan the clan we had three full pages up
and running this week that means three
full pages of clan members out here
getting busy what I don't like by you
guys on what y'all do is y'all send me a
message you'll see me in the chat if the
chat is not full of 16 people
I want you jumping in jump in I want you
accent questions as will run you through
yeah this your gaming
everybody on unless I want you to go
through your clans list and I want you
to go pick a guy and talk to him get in
the womb make a chat there's a part
the party so please be courteous when
you come in the party yeah yes don't
call it coming to party dropping f-bombs
and this down the third and slurs and
stuff like that come in there feel the
temperature of the room get to know
people in there and then let it grow I
would like to give a shout out to a lot
of new classmates that I've met um drag
a deaf clutch which is absolutely
probably the funniest guy going new cats
the most adorable daughter um man I
wanna shout out on bootytime bootytime
bootytime yes I was just about same time
these these guys are jumping in and
they're making itself known shout out to
the our super trihard gamers tag Lion
spinister these guys are bringing my
gaming up to a whole nother level all
right
and we are reaching back and pulling
everybody up if your need raids and
stuff this is really not the week to
come at us because we're trying to train
our characters up to get them all to
purple and then we're gonna start doing
the rage from there and knocking off
those checklists so we can get our
masterworks on our armor and have
everybody four or five so we're playing
really hard um but that's the only thing
I've been playing I don't even plan on a
weekend but I've been consumed with this
game destiny is back in such a way that
it took my pub G time yes cheating is
not an option I don't want sick and
tired of hearing people complain that oh
you didn't have content destiny doesn't
do grind his garni the grind is back
where are you all right also if your
clan doesn't play actively cuz I'm not
playing with non clan members I'm gonna
let you know right now it may sound like
i'm bougie or because i jumped in a room
and to do was in there that wasn't part
of my clan and i said oh these dudes in
the clan he said no and I left oh I
don't have time for them because I have
clam mates that need
you know you got guys that only work on
the weekends that need to get the
whisper who goon is it who needs help in
inclusive because we got to do crucible
so we'd rather run as a team mmm-hmm if
your clan is not running if your clan is
not playing if your know you're ranking
high you're getting your clan stuff and
they're not there for you leave them
join us iron Lords podcast join us leave
them alone throw them in the bushes
because they don't there's not worth
your time we gonna break them up I like
that and those bushes have stickies so
you can look pretty much the same thing
for me you know it's been pretty much
destiny almost full-time summer solstice
taking up a lot of my time I snuck in
both the EA access demos of Madden 19
and I know doing good man 4k it's just
so beautiful 4k HD oh yeah I know I know
where's getting weak I will say I was
gonna save that for special guests so
hold on to that door because we're going
to address that at some point I'm not
gonna let that slip I just want I have
the perfect guest for that topic and
it'll be a surprise hopefully within the
next week you too for them yeah NHL 19
and then um still what I can't talk
about which is killing me I'm still on
the halo Master Chief collection but
very positive stuff screenshots coming
out today you know I'm like in the third
round I'm waiting for ya I'm at the top
level I might I'm in the third round for
that I cannot wait to be is that our
fantastic from what so far so you know
more to disclose as the week's go on but
let's get into the poll last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the rumors
of a second Xbox garlic cloud skill
being discovered how confident you
confident are you that Microsoft can
resolve the latency issues generally
associated with cloud gaming the winner
at 55% in a fairly competitive three-way
ILP poll was yes Microsoft was on the
right track with scarlet cloud
coming in that second at 23% it was the
no not confidence called a cloud over
traditional constantly a coming in at a
razor close third place at 22% was that
I don't care Microsoft power of the
cloud is equal to Skynet but I want to
first shout out run to Rome and a mana
respect Great Wall himself Lord bills
skill will from the Xbox platform and
backward compatibility team who had a
very cryptic three word response on
Twitter to our Pope and all these that
was I'm pretty confident that that's was
very surprising me and me and Lord
addict had this discussion offline as
well soft and it was just one of those
things that like wow you know and the
reason why I said because obviously we
you know Lord bills a friend to the
realm and we know his role at Microsoft
he has to deal with backward
compatibility you know so if anybody
might have some insight you know he will
God so to see him come out strongly you
know with that you know response you
know what do you what do you think Louis
are what do you what do you think about
it like in reference to what maybe he
has seen already that I mean listen
that's all it took for me to be like you
up there on the right track like that's
all it took me like I don't see them
making a hard push into this unless they
figured something out right it doesn't
make sense they'd come out with the same
technique that we've been saying for
years so I'm just excited to see what
that is see what it is yeah laboum woody
what do you feel about this uh whole the
whole latency thing and a good friend of
Lord bill still oh well let me let me
just say this Microsoft we we have seen
from 2013 to just before e3 2018 a
Microsoft on the ropes yes okay now and
I'm saying this is this is not to insult
anyone's plastic box
you have to admit that there is a
changing of the guards in regards to
confidence yes with Microsoft and Sony
because you see since e3 2018 Microsoft
has been coming out like the bully I
probably drop in lots of information
lots of SKUs you know lots of you know
you know you know secret information
hiring at this company buying this
company you know word we may see another
one or two companies being brought up
and announced at Gamescom these are all
the the hot ticket information that
we've been getting from the Microsoft
camp
whereas Sony has had really kind of been
you know they kind of fumbled a few
times you know I'm saying and now we're
first and goal on their one okay because
you had the cross-play incident right
that that's kind of still hanging out
there behind right then you have all of
this or all of these you know these
fumbles with you know with press and you
know mistakes that you don't see Sony
making so when you see Microsoft saying
yeah we have our traditional box
underneath your TV so don't sweat it
old-school gamers but if let's say
friends since you're that old-school
gamer that listen let's call a spade a
spade guys there are a lot of people
that own multiple Xboxes yes right
because you know you may have one in
your den you may have one upstairs you
may have one for your son or your
daughter right game share 101 right one
of the liver on one of the bedroom
absolutely so what's wrong with this
being being the second there you go it's
gonna be a hundred or 150 dollars I
guarantee you will be going out to buy
that but I got one even better what what
is what what it feels Spencer say he
wanted to do he wanted an Xbox in every
mofos house yes and when you're telling
people that we can stream 4k
visuals to your TV for a hundred and
fifty dollars
mm-hmm people will be consider people
that's the that is the magic price point
in that would get someone the casual
gamer yes we'll get the PlayStation 4
game and say wait a second for a hundred
bucks 150 bucks I can get a new xbox and
be playing what I'm gonna check this out
and that's how they get that box that's
one box in everyone's house and just
just to double down on what you said
kind of talked about this last IOP and I
want to shout out the Xbox to Randy just
go in fantastic show um basically they
kind of on the same wave got what we
don't on which is kind of like look if
they can pull though obviously latency
is always an issue data caps always the
issue you know your internet was always
an issue but if they proposed not only
do you have this a cheap affordable
console that can you know be appealing
to a casual market but then they're
talking remember Phil got on stage you
know he said they showed mobile devices
you know if they're reaching this target
number that they're trying to get into
the billions or whatever it is that you
can't penetrate that market with just
consoles
markets their weekend like again me and
King talked about this last happy you
know like Japan you know and stuff like
that
you know you have this thing able to do
in a more on a mobile phone or mobile
device on a me if you even if it's not
4k let's just say it's 1080p 60 you know
or based on whatever your stream
requirements is that's pretty appealing
so again it's early we still don't know
all the details we still don't know
everything but you know based on what
the rumors are suggesting but I'm trying
to eliminate the latency with the you
know the actual chipset in the box and
for inputs and stuff like that right you
know this is something that no one else
is doing this is not similar to a PS now
this is not similar you know there's
some aspects in an Nvidia shield repre
is in there but it's not a one-to-one
match this is also them expanding or
something and like Louis off said you
know if they're talking you know they
may be confident something that may be a
breakthrough and if it is a breakthrough
that would be huge for the industry so
great great great question right there
and great topic for a lower bill
Stillwell boom let's get into these uh
journey up so you know I'll be cooking
up at the end this show Lord King real
quick though real quick
Loic a daddy graciously offered to
reroll his $20 gift card he's filling in
the giving mood so we're gonna do that
real quick okay
cats out the cat daddy and relevant
native yes he gonna go just like King
and cradles are wanting to save me and
cat daddy one in the same real quick so
the winner of the $20 gift card thanks
to cat daddy fat stacks is Lord J
Fonzarelli I feel good about that one
brother we'll get that to you thank you
daddy
any savage man there we go a little loss
we got to pick up the pace on Lord K you
are up NP Dino's so the bet is over you
better be no what's crazy no no you not
technically yes I'm going to because
that was unprecedent what happened was
was something cuz it's a Nintendo
product so it's a Nintendo product
[Laughter]
system this is how you know gaming is at
its purest form is when you can just
game how you want to gain where you want
to gain with what you want a game right
and this thing this system has taken on
a life of its own now I'm pretty sure
that Nintendo had all the thoughts and
ideas of putting Virtual Console in the
switch it was like success before so it
should be a success now but this mini is
winning why should we make us a Virtual
Console on the switch when we could sell
these games 15 at a time on these little
boxes and get it out there my question
to the realm mm-hmm is the success of
the many at the detriment and the demise
of the Virtual Console on a switch let's
get let's get addict in on this I'm very
curious about his position on this I've
said from the start they're not going to
do nothing because that's selling like
all kegs I'm with you bro
winning July do you know what the minis
winning July I mean yeah isn't that
crazy I mean it's I guess they just
restocks that's what I was thinking yeah
you know I know I know it's true shout
out on to my job is actually our game
what actually work with a lot of gamers
and um a lot of one of my boys actually
like a week or two ago he comes up he's
like yeah man I got it
and I'm like yeah you know what I don't
know was Amazon or whatever they must
have been a huge restock that it has to
be because I'm noticing people now post
it and getting it up but to still you
know they'll be the PlayStation 4 and
Xbox with the mini like that's great
what do you think about this ball man
like well well let's just let's bring
some knowledge bring out there okay
first of all it launched on November
11th 2016 oh good point okay we are now
in 2018 okay so we're almost coming up
on two years listen the thing is this
honest with you the Xbox the PlayStation
and the swish need a hotel for that look
you got there's a couple things you got
to remember here first of all it's it's
the summer and it's it's slow right so
smart on Nintendo to push these out the
door but
specifically their 60 bucks did a price
in the game and you're getting 30 games
and you know what gaming in 2018 isn't
your your teeny box you know there are
30 40 and 50 year old people gaming and
to be quite honest with you you're
getting a perfect representation of
those older games in one little box well
it's it's the people that would purchase
this they're the ones that that have the
financial revenue in regards to whether
or not was your folk of like the 20 year
like the high teens and 20 year-olds
most of them are buying this and they're
playing for at night afford to buy games
they got away from mom-and-pop we were
all there I mean listen I'm not gonna
front I I hustled from my gaming it
where was no waiting I don't care if I
had to do six we do get to do but in
regards in regards to hurting the the
virtual console you know what it
absolutely is and here's why we know
that we have the NES mini and the Super
NES mini and we know and it's and it's
already its facts out there and I did a
story on my channel months and months
ago about how the in the trademarks the
n64 mini was was trademarked you know
we're gonna get an energy attack yeah
we're definitely getting an N 16 and
we're gonna get a Gamecube because they
do the a 64 mini if there's some way and
I know this is cutting into it stops
rant later I'll be if this didn't get
them wrestling games I don't know if the
license issues you'd love to see
wrestlemania 2000 and now oh yeah all
that good stuff
absolutely what yeah the reason why ok
you got to look at it from two ways yes
it's hurting it
but at the same time do you want to be
the cat like me that by Super Mario
World for the 17th time because we all
did that you know don't transfer the
licenses so we the the we you you you
know the game Gameboy this game whether
you buying these games one after another
you don't mind the minis having like a
little collection of games you just plug
it in and you go you played for a week
you put it away and then when you get
installed your bug you put it out mm-hmm
and you play it again so don't be
surprised that once they're done
releasing these minis because you know
there are only so many nao Nintendo
consoles
there you're gonna see an NES mini two
with these dirty games that weren't on
the first I'm such a
I'm such an Abu but I will be going and
buying those things every one of them
you know just in reference to the actual
MPD part I just want to talk about that
look for in an aqua God going to mini
yeah may just the industry's just so
healthy right now just seeing it on and
like with the mini just come being a
surprise PlayStation 4 let's not forget
they still won in dollar sales revenue
you know we gotta give props to them on
that and even though everyone's like all
Xbox losing and Xbox is that dead double
they nearly double for the map as far as
hardware sales so again it's like me and
King always say we use like a a music
reference right it's like you know
PlayStation is drink right now
he doesn't know every you know album but
you got Xbox going gold and still doing
better than the 360 where error in
financially so people this is a
misconception out there because they're
not winning the MPD's that all of a
sudden you know it means that the system
is a failure right and that you see that
that rhetoric and as far as the meaning
which is to King's question which is
like yeah I gave up man I can see the
Kings right I just think is one of those
things as bad as I want
Virtual Console on switch there's no way
I can see it comment me and this thing
these many consoles are so dominate
sales wire they have no incentive to do
it they have a way what's gonna happen
is I guarantee you when the game
the mini enqueue that's when they'll
start doing the switch they gonna rock
out this whole cycle we all say and I
think that's what it's just a moneymaker
and only my only person and I think I
think that mindsets hurting them overall
right now right it's it's like a 3ds
thing it's like look if I understand
that's a huge market mm-hmm
but like you're trying to grow the
switch market that's one of the reasons
the way you felt is because they built
it and I'm like I get it it's a big you
know it's a big thing that you build a
huge brand but you you are sacrificing
the brand you're trying to build two
main right to maintain the older II do I
not get it and here's the thing we all
know Nintendo beats to their own drum
and one thing you know with the Wii
being you know it's funny the other
consoles they will on occasional been to
like the social media aspect yeah but
Nintendo it's hard to for them again
just if you look at it not as a gamer
look at it as pure business it's hard to
fault them to stop the 3ds market is
still huge right then it's still selling
the winning NPD you mean like the best
way to spotlight their stuff I don't
think I don't think we would have gotten
Virtual Console in the same way that we
have in the past just because if you
look at everything the Virtual Console
encompassed in the past it wasn't just
their stuff it was trouble graphics yeah
and like I'm a huge shinobi fan and I
saw it was wrong we so I'm like oh this
is definitely coming to switch now I
can't get any I feel like okay Pokemon
like I want them to use their handheld
like they did with like the n64 doing an
automated the n64 I did yes the Gamecube
but they don't it's like its own entity
now yes correct
that's that's where the issues are
having like what they need to go now is
because they're both portable they have
like Pokemon
the colors like they've been doing
that's instead of having both of them on
the 3ds for both them on the switch
split them up once on the switch once on
the 3ds and they can cross play and play
against each other that low dose cool
style
I don't stock in any game and company
still MPD's don't mean anything to me
just enjoying playing on whatever system
I feel or dos cosas I mean just finish
again the finishing my point I think
it's just one of those things that my
last hope for any type of Virtual
Console is when they launch this online
services of death you know and we know
what a good office inside games just ice
climbing as it I think that's one of the
reasons that we haven't seen them vetted
in the market is because they want to
use it is like that get this and you
like if you want my honest opinion yeah
all they would have to do to keep a lot
of people happy is put a bunch of those
in like a service like game has but
instead of game pass being its own
entity with my price point it's just
like you you subscribe to our online on
the switch you get access to listen
genomic people will fly to that service
even cuz everybody's upset with it
because of the voice chat situation but
people would fly to it for something
like that
yep sure would it is absolutely insane
for them to even think about saying now
you know we're gonna think about the
consumer I don't ever believe Nintendo
was ever consumer they dish they just
pretty much almost finished the Wii U we
all know that guy hit up that GameCube
library made a bunch of stuff on that
will do I would buy on this way Luigi's
Mansion
I would bind this exact week there's
always that game even though we can play
with Nintendo practices
there's always that door that's what
Luigi's Mansion is only on the 3ds
no we're such suckers when it comes to
this is how much of a suckle we offer
does not bog neighs this
here you go play with this suckers
Michael said cardboard no it wouldn't
never made it but I'm pretty sure
somebody in the boardroom yelled out
yeah I got a cardboard game there are
certain games out there that they can
literally keep bringing back out on
another people like Final Fantasy 7 I've
bought they know that their base will
bend the knee - no that's just what it
and me that's why I can't knock I got to
be Lord corporate right now I understand
what they if they brought a legend in
soda collector's edition for the switch
with majora as hell they can literally
bring them all individually and I would
buy them all at forty to fifty dollars a
pop because you know that's coming you
know 3ds versions gonna be upscaled and
brought on this pass and then looking
from the perspective when those games
came out on the 3ds they were huge they
sold really well the moment they come on
the switch that's one of the reasons
that gank you did one when it first came
out the door because it came with the
Legend of Zelda :
if you look on ebay right now that game
with the case is for like $100 yeah real
quick in the chat we move on or face 20
feet BK and why just tells us that
powerfully doesn't mean anything and
Victor Allison has a question Saab red
dragon put out a video with a question
asking why has an Xbox one NPD in almost
two years I said we just have solve
answering because
for him you know what his answer was
poor marketing what's your answer as far
as NPM for having one MPD in need to fix
temp marketing yeah I said this last
week they need to want whenever the next
consoles come out they have to be very
clear about their messaging especially
if you communicate on a cloud absolutely
like if they don't yeah it's tough
because you're not gonna get you're not
gonna get the casual person
understanding we're trying to sell and I
just actually watched that video not too
long ago like an hour ago when I was
driving back when it comes to that
particular like I have to agree with red
dragon it's not a coincidence that the
like you know where I'm when the S came
out that's when you know Forza horizon 3
and all that started dropping gears yeah
it's not a coincidence the s helped but
it was those bomb games that dropped em
yeah Sal brother
yeah multi plats
keep people on a platform but exclusives
it by the plan holder wait man whole day
away from the gaming habits affecting
you know I'm gonna turn into a werewolf
or something
attics issues he's up next Eric could
you got your favorite franchise what's
going on I mean there was a website that
was that came up random good be bunked
already but like I can't yes
let's go like I feel like I feel like
maybe someone like I still think it's
it's still legit because like here's the
thing like the way that okay first off
it was called Reaver
okay let me just explain history because
yes non fabled mine my night fable self
needs to be a website was lit red river
industries that's the exact name of a
character that was in fable 2 called the
hero skill he was a hero skills one of
the main characters okay he was pretty
much like that you know the dude that
didn't care like it and in fable 3 he
was he was trying to get you to sign off
on child labor and fable 3 Weber
Industries was like the the underlying
like corporate like monopoly in the
whole world that was like controlling
everything and they like again they had
like slave laborers they were like grimy
stuff like the hope would a fable 3 is
like you try to overthrow this this
deity okay when you you you get all
these people to help you do it but the
plot twist of the game is at the end of
fable 3 you had to make decisions as the
king if you were going to abide to what
you promised these people throw I'm one
of them and so it was pretty much going
like a courtroom like on the line was
the person that you promised on the
right was Reaper one of them was like
like you know they enslave our our
children they do that in like and what's
funny is like though they'll come at you
and then river the river coma pretty
much on the side okay man I know what he
said look how much money we gonna lose
it
nice businessman the try to influence
you and I'm not gonna lie
there was child labor but anyway so what
happened his own logo this website was
brought up to the said Sabri /
industries that had the little go then
yeah it was these act local no it must
look like it was different but I would
go around that you know Walmart's logo
hasn't looked the same in 10 years
people change their logos it's still the
same but it's reimagined as the same
logo like for instance our logo we've
had the same logo but we put different
the designs been different stupid he
said it all makes sense that advocates
to me it was like 200 billion if you
don't make these kids do your work I was
like here have mine they did publicly
say it on their Twitter account it
wasn't connected to fable but I'm like
look you have a company called River
industries you have a logo that is that
first off on the website it said open to
the public in 2020 which let me assume
the next Xbox yep
so I'm like ok there is a good chance
that you know this was clearly not this
is clearly just a coincidence right
someone else took that and one would
think if if they made that could what
Microsoft had will copyrighted that name
River industries like I don't know how
that works but anyway but you know when
you put it from that perspective you can
take it you know it's just a complete
coincidence has nothing to do with
Microsoft or you could go to the
direction well somewhat accidentally
launched it and didn't realize they
launched it and
two minutes at the table but I have to
kind of I kind of feel were you going
because it's almost it's almost too
coincident arremer if it was like that
you don't say now I'm going to give it
right back to you let's just clarify
what a loss am I put out the in article
fantastic article following this whole
Weaver industries yeah um so basically
they've now come out since and said as
big fans of the fable series we started
state that this account is not owned by
Microsoft or any of its affiliates it's
not it is not a hint to a new fable game
so they try to get in front of it and
kind of debunk that put up like what do
you guys think Larry a do you well go
back and what you about at the end of
the day it's probably just a coincidence
but I'm like if you have you have
regular industries which you know is the
exact name they used in the game you
have the pretty much the exact same logo
and you have 2020 being open to the
public that's a weird statement to use
on a website Oakland to the public like
double love like why would you say
something like to them is it like a park
or something let's get a little boom in
man boom what do you feel about all this
uh favor rumors and I also had it we
didn't talk about the the bigger news I
felt which is um you know obviously
playground with it yeah I just got to
stay something irrelevant the morning
was fake okay just like the earth is
flat oh don't get fleet leaving all
right
oh yeah they've got the second studio
and this is gonna be mostly dedicated to
this quote-unquote top-secret project
project we all notice Facebook and you
know they've made all these hides right
they got like some environment artists
who start so much battle for to you know
they got some also environmentalist from
various Bioware games script writers
from Batman Arkham
they got animators devil may cry and
hell-blade like this is like an all spar
hiring group you know so global what do
you feel about the rumors and then also
playground games in general you know
what fable doubling down well I got
something here this is this is this is
not any kind of inside baseball
explosive bomb is my opinion following
the story so people take and run with
this and you know somehow I get the
bunked it's my opinion it's not fact oh
okay now we got the table let's go
these hires is not the first round of
hires this is actually the third round
yeah actually shout out the Lord saying
in their actual article they actually
hired people from like gta5 yes like six
months ago
yeah Metal Gear Solid five there was a
few those few big names up in there okay
now check this out from what I have
heard hmm exclusive okay
they approached Microsoft with an
open-world game that they were creating
right okay
Microsoft according to my sources Phil
said no but would you like to do fable
now now here's the thing there has been
way way too much big-name hiring for
fable for so here's my exclusive what
you thinking not only are they working
on Microsoft's label fable whatever
they're hiring for their game you're
gonna make them both at the same time or
might then make that what I think was
yes I think what they're doing is
they're going to be making fable and
taking the knowledge from that game over
to their own game which of course is
going to be under the Microsoft brand
because Microsoft now owns playground
games again this is complete speculation
but it's just too many too many big-name
hires for one game it just it doesn't
all point to if you want my opinion I
really feel like that because I feel
like play
ground was they weren't like od'd on
making forza horizon but they wanted it
make something different they couldn't
get because you know they went to
multiple people to try to set fire that
dad is correct after they couldn't I
really think that you know Microsoft
used that brand it's like look like you
guys want to make this we can't like
obviously they've been burnt too many
times like we right we already own
fables that's not interview yeah we need
your I think they tried they use that
second studio to like what the agreement
that they would fund that second studio
to buy playground in general mmm that's
a lot of people really want because
playground was very open that they were
wanted to be independent and then all of
a sudden they're making a fable now and
they like Michael I gotta get none of us
said any of this is fact it's all shadow
secondly if Abel is not a franchise you
like that fine I've always saying is if
these rumors are true
that um if there's a second franchise
maybe that could be the franchise for
you if you don't like fail so that's
what we guys listen again what we when
you see a studio high or a couple of
big-name guys to be lead producer lead
are you know you know artists you know
leaves graphics whatever however you
want to put it
do you like okay they're working on a
big game but when you start seeing them
pull together so many and these aren't
just your regular its all-star cast
these are people that have led teens yes
yes and I'm saying you know what I want
to bring up real quick to like all the
shine is on the second let's be regular
this second company the second studio
for playgrounds getting all this this
this this you know this spotlight it's
looking like it's gonna be like the
their go-to for RPG and we still have no
idea what initiative is making and is
literally the studio that was designed
Julie say it right quietly so like it's
nice to see that like Microsoft's like
look we got we're tired of being made
fun of over exclusives yeah we're done
real quick
boss booth says play gun games Faber was
gonna have horse race I know
no people laughing don't be surprised
over the right he says keeping my new
fable with sign before Phil's promotion
and people always try to like poke at me
when I say that you know I think Faye
was going to be an Xbox the next Xbox
exclusive and right there where save
just said this game is development for a
little bit they're generating odd people
to help with the development now no
doubt loss Ovid King and focus will be
the more what do you feel about this uh
the rumors yes you don't bring on these
people for one game especially a game
that's been that say the game is sort of
been in production a year and a half
maybe to two years it's it's it's in the
it's in the weeds in terms of just being
develop now deciphering no offense but
the entire destiny community went
together to solve a binary listen I I
get that part right and that like I said
that for me I would sort of paint
because when you posted it and I looked
at I said oh god right literally I say
Oh God and it's going to be a situation
where people are deciphering the words
and if you take the first letter of
every other
word Babel every topic we're gonna have
coming down the pipeline
how many top we talked about those we do
like just Carlene fair still a lot of
speculation we know that a fable game is
coming and we do hopefully I hope garlic
I hope it's a launch title like they
learn a great game of that don't put it
on this relic there's a good chance I
don't know about fable fable could come
out the year after the next time I
wanted that day but it's looking like if
I were if I were to be a guessing that
it's looking like Halo a and fame or
gonna be launch titles yes Lani maybe
somethin fishy topic anymore
exactly you have a Forza right to show
off you know you know car games over I
think fable is gonna be very attractive
game oh absolutely
has to be I don't know if you get both
Halo and fable like if I think fable was
I mean halos for sure gonna be a
longshot about that I would say a
hundred percent chance
I mean 99 I'll say 99 oh here's that one
the way you know I used to kind of think
that the Xbox is coming out next year
but now that I look at it from that
perspective like I think that gears is
going to be one of the last and last oh
yeah Xbox one is yes and then the year
after that they're going to do their own
launch event for the yet the next Xbox
then that III they're gonna law they're
gonna announce the next table with
gameplay and fable and then that's when
it's coming out yeah it's very possible
song finish up this and then we can move
on to the next seven I think I think
fable come if it's ready to go launch I
can see it only if cyberpunk isn't
coming out 2020 okay I don't know I
think cyber perks coming too
okay back to what we're saying about
speculation right so this past week
there were two articles that I saw
initially but an article by NN Tech and
then a second article that came out
yesterday from Richard Ledbetter at
digital foundry talking about how AMD
has collaborated with Chinese hardware
manufacturer to create a new console
console hardware for the Chinese market
which has really not been seen before um
and the interesting thing about this
console is that a is using the system on
a chip the same way that you're using
the ps4 Pro in the xbox so it's not
traditional its its traditional console
hardware in that respect but this same
system on a chip is being used in PC
hardware in China which is very
interesting because we haven't seen
anything like that and it could pave the
way for smaller form factor semi
powerful pcs um in the future not and
the other interesting thing about this
that goes to a speculating about the
next consoles coming down the pipeline
is that this is the first system on a
chip that has been produced with rising
in it we was hoping for Scorpio
exactly when we speculated before
Scorpio came out that they were gonna
use rising all on their system-on-a-chip
and instead what they did was they
souped up several era scores and and
thus we don't have a CPU bottleneck so
this is again this is interesting
because it's the first system on a chip
we've seen with rise and awning and from
what they've talked about with the
breakdown of this this system on a chip
is very close and power to what a ps4
pro gives you the difference is that it
achieves ps4 it achieves that power in a
different way than the ps4 probe does ok
because here they bump up the CPU which
is what people want to see how all right
that's our frames right there's a bump
in the CPU gonna help the bottleneck
right right so it has less RAM right so
it's different it's it's lower than the
ps4 Pro in certain aspects but the CPU
prop up is what pushes it to that level
so one thing that Richard Ledbetter said
which is very interesting is he said the
the CPU Ike we've talked about the CPU
is the key is the key if you can get if
you can get a three gigahertz CPU in
console hardware you're you're
essentially guaranteeing yourself 60
frames per second gameplay absolutely
it's a matter of cost-effectiveness
right no doubt let me ask you this
question because obviously you got a
technical or but um my thing was like
ultimately I like lucky said like I just
want to know like how is this going to
affect next generation consoles we know
ps5 is common we know Xbox 2 or whatever
name they're gonna call it is coming and
my main issue basically is
cost-effectiveness right and like you
said 60 frames because it's powerful as
a score is right we all know that ships
that the CPU is the only whole back
right the GPU fantastic but the cpu is
the only whole back and that's why you
know they get clowned a little bit like
ok what happened a 4k 6 the
uncorruptible I thought everything yeah
and it's not there on every title so
what you're saying I add my question
back to you solve is like what you're
saying do you think with this custom
soccer Andy do you think that Marcus or
for Sony is going to expound
on that also do you think like oh maybe
just use it itself or and just on my
price cutting like does this effect like
2020s when we most likely expect these
new consoles right so like does that
affect that line that's coming soon like
how do you feel in relation to the
next-gen consoles well I think it
guarantees that we at least see some
form of Rison on these system on the
jobs for the next guarantees that it
guarantees yes um I think both console
makers are going to blow these specs out
of the water
yeah if you look at now the question is
in terms of the CPU since everything is
on one chip we get to that point yeah of
course these guys have the relationship
with Nvidia or something like that
well Sony something the switch the
switch today I mean if they're gonna do
a switch 2.0 unless they're working with
somebody else on stuff on some sort of
small form-factor tech and then the
expectation is that it would be some
form of the Tegra 2.0 is that good right
god I don't unless there's something
doing something secretive and they're
not working with Nvidia anymore um
another interesting thing is is that if
you think about the moves that Microsoft
isn't making recently with Nvidia
themselves like the new the new AP the
the new API that's gonna focus a lot on
the um ty what the heck is it the ray
tracing stun ray tracing - yeah that's
in conjunction with Nvidia right so it's
kind of up in the air I mean maybe not
maybe not but for me it's kind of up in
the air who they go with for the next
console because this is so integrated
into this now mind you ain't he does
have their own solution for this and AMD
have been the ones willing to to build
these custom chips right um so it's
gonna be interesting to see what these
chips look like but I think this gives
us a baseline to start speculating about
what we're
see but I think yeah you got these are
good
whatever the PlayStation 5 is the next
Xbox is gonna blow this stuff out of the
water a little but when you feel it all
that stuff man
well I I'm gonna tell you this Microsoft
will never be behind the eight ball ever
again completely understand where Lord
and Savior I mean they know what they
did wrong in 2013 where they bet they
tried to over balance what happened with
with with the actual console and the
Kinect where the Kinect was instead of
the the console being the lead it was
they wanted to change the world with
Kinect and they understand that they
made a mistake so if they've taken all
of this time to get us the X which we
all have and love and power which is not
talked about in the mass media anymore
since Microsoft has that and they're not
the media darlings anymore is where it's
where it's at and all I'm gonna say in
regards to this is I have the actual
article in front of me AMD has T as
collaborated with the hardware
manufacturer I think it's pronounced
hung shot honks uber support yeah listen
this is this when you see technology
like this it's great because you know
and you hit the really at a point we are
no for an actual fact that rise in will
be in the next console and that is a big
deal because the CPU has been the
hang-up a GPU is fantastic the CPUs you
know we get that bottleneck and you
can't do what you really want to do III
think you're right I think that both the
PlayStation 5 and the Xbox 2 whatever
you want to call it are gonna blow these
specks out of the water 100% this is
exciting stuff right now I like that a
soft brought that to the table anybody
got anything else on the AMD sock or
should we move on to the finals so
because
I thought attic wasn't gonna be here so
I had it so real quick um Def Jam has
been hinting at the possible return of
another
Def Jam fighting game since June and
June they they put like a silhouette on
a PlayStation cover saying who would you
like on the cover of a new Def Jam last
week they they kind of hinted like what
city would you like it's sudden is like
well they're really doing this like at
the same time I was excited I know I was
excited at the same time like completely
shut down because yeah I think it's
moves are the best and that's all agree
I would not put it past them to make
some mobile thing with this right that's
one thing that's one this thing that's
disheartening secondly I if it doesn't
have that a key engine I'm not touching
it exactly and it goes to my this this
goes this goes to my heart what is this
related to that was just gonna tell you
to shut your mic off now if I can't get
meth and Redman to do it's not happening
and this goes back to this this Aki
wrestling slash fighting game engine
this is the stuff of legend it is into
this day has not been surpassed in
bringing the feeling of pro wrestling
facts to life yep I don't care what you
can see WCW versus end up your wort or
world gold revenge revenge
these games what they do that to me is
still witchcraft under the under the
hood because you didn't know what was
happening right you you had you could be
good at the game right and if you're
fighting someone until they got black
mouth though yeah that was you remember
those hockey engine but it didn't work
it would be like hollow souls and we
call it that guys in the chat who were
not around I didn't play these games you
have to understand what these games are
and reach honestly guys like there's no
game that we went bonkers for more as a
group yes well actually one halo like
nobody we all pitch them for two
televisions a folder rustling flown goes
to my point those games right those
PlayStation Smackdown vs. raw they don't
hold the candle to these n64 games and
it's because of the gameplay that yeah
you know that engine you could go in and
and you you could be beating up on
somebody if you make one mistake and you
allow them to get this spirit meter
everything the whole flow of the fight
can change this guy's whipping long
could turn around and beat you that's
that's the product that professional
wrestling is yeah not these games now
they're more like a fighting game if you
would on somebody from the beginning of
the match you're gonna beat him period
he's not yeah that's that's the start of
the terrible we hated them
you know that's just my mini ran I'm
glad that they're even talking about
this stuff all those Def Jam games were
fantastic they they expanded on the
engines that we saw initially in the n64
in a way that was that was great um yeah
but I I'm saddened because I don't think
it's gonna be anything that we care
about to the police-station team
everyone hyped up and it turned out it
was a mobile game it was a football game
I thought it was coming it was supposed
to be exclusive yes what I guess they
thought Sports Talk was coming back you
know
shoutout to UK dad's Undertaker versus
gold Nick over oh man match no doubt
yeah and like like loss offset the a key
fighting system those wrestling games to
me were superior to counter system the
interaction and as they evolved you can
make your own pay-per-view it was just
it was such a back-and-forth I mean we
would all put our names in hat so you
don't say decide what type of match is
gonna be a triple threat a battle royal
whatever or Ramu determines champions in
each division make belts we would go so
crazy with this thing nothing without
the actual was it 300 hours
there's no and literally whoever would
win would get to go home that week there
was one there was one Lord
when he lost the king he was forced to
crawl on the Kings legs Wow the king was
now over him my best match was drew we
had to carry me on his back down the
block fun times
oh no no no no no no my best my best
game that I've ever won has to be
against Lord black magic Oh black magic
God where he had to walk down the street
there's a lot of scar human beings walk
if that's the origins of me that's how
all of that all that's thought well
you're fantastic so we gotta move on too
soon I'm gonna rush through this last
time because I know we run over all
right so we've got some news from our
good friend Hudson you know talking
about body weight I'm definitely gonna
pass off the boom because you know we
actually obviously it was an anthem
panel and faxing you know there was some
talk about you know the future of the
Mass Effect franchise Dragon Age
franchise and one thing I also want to
talk about too which I think a lot of
people don't really mention a lot in
regards to anthem is the approach I want
to shout out Laura samuel tobert of
course our Lord editor dtic
games network.com and he put out this
article as well in reference to Casey
Hudson so basically what they're saying
is Casey saying is it's gonna be a combo
experience and this is kind of also
shout about Eric's when we had him on
and he kind of hinted that to us and we
didn't realize it remember we were doing
holding destiny to Hoover's division two
versed in
who's gonna survive and all that and he
said look you made a great point said
these guys anthem maybe going for
something completely different and the
vibe I'm getting from Casey Hudson now
is that in the combo single-player
experience and then a multiplayer
experience and he mentioned that so
let's get into all this Bioware talk I
courage your podcast you got a fantastic
topic panel with this topic so imma let
you set this off like what do you feel
about all of this information coming out
from Casey let's see well first and
foremost you have to understand
something the reason why a Andromeda
took the El was because Casey Hudson
wasn't wasn't beating that's the bottom
line
this this the Casey Hudson's back story
with Mass Effect is I hope he writes a
book because you have to understand the
passion that this man has for that
franchise he called it his child you
don't say that about a franchise unless
you give a s about it right is this your
bandit duh you know he's he's the type
that moves around from different things
like he kind of gets disinterested and
comes back and yeah I mean he was
getting a little burnt out on the edge
with the Mass Effect thing and he left
to where he left to go work at Microsoft
to kind of I guess cool his Jets a bit
yeah he was opposed to be on the
hololens project yeah yes yeah he was on
there for a while I don't think I don't
think he did much when he was there he
just kind of just recharged his
batteries I am gonna say this that that
midsummer update that they posted on
Bioware's blog where he said that this
is his exact quote we hear you loud and
clear the interest in bio we're doing
more Dragon Age and more Mass Effect so
rest assured that we have some teams
hidden away working on some secret stuff
that I think you're all gonna really
like we're just not ready to talk about
that for a little while now there's a
couple of things that you can take away
from this first of all understand that a
Mass Effect a proper Mass Effect is
coming so that's dope okay but here's
the other thing and I thought I did a
poll over the weekend I've been I've
been tweeting that EA I've been tweeting
that Bioware
I think it's about high time that they
just already cut the BS never release a
4k HD over of Mass Effect 1 1 2 3 let's
go add the deal charge me 59.95 I get
you I'll tell you this right now
whatever month that that came that game
comes out and is winning NPD number one
and considering that at EA I'm very
surprised that we have not seen that as
of yet alright I just got I got a good
statement to say by then so everyone
that want that loves Dragon Age that
loves Bioware don't buy anthem why if it
comes out it is kicking and they making
buku some money they ain't going back to
those friends think that they have a
Bioware with such a such a big team and
there's such a historic teams that we
this is a gold money like let's say that
comes out and that is doing numbers and
that gives them incentive to make this
prophecy go that the fans woman yeah we
a lot of companies when they hate a
goldmine they don't just go make us
something to that gold mines and
continue to mine that property and so
that property goes dry yeah yeah does
that that stay and what you're saying
the only thing I think is different in
this case with Mass Effect is that it is
well regarded that the first three are
revered right those are active yeah
everyone was disgusted with I should say
everyone but most people consider
Andromeda a media yeah not a terrible
game what a mediocre bad it was received
initially remember those dreams and
those graphical glitches so the thing is
people at that point was like damn
because of this kind of stumble with
Andromeda now we have no hope of getting
another proper Mass Effect so now do
they bring Casey back who's kind of like
the father of Mass Effect
we came out you know that III on Xbox
stage with the param I who's the
governess game looks cool when they had
conversation choices and all this stuff
like they debuted and remember this was
an Xbox exclusive correct yeah so I'll
throw T this way then let's say that the
game comes out extremely successful when
they do know I'm talking about anthem
being successfully hit them because
they're making MOBA Cuza money from
let's say that that does happen and
they're like okay we're making a lot of
money we can fund three Bioware's I've
got me three mass affects what happens
if they try to take a Bioware through
the anthem approach he's like let's make
it more like destiny and making an
open-world theme that a games a service
like it can happen like it can happen
there's no there's no doubt you know
that game comes out and it's extremely
successful and EA finally gets that
destiny money that you know constant
revenue coming in constantly like they
have their sports right right absolutely
it's going to drastically change
something like I don't disagree I'm a
Mass Effect head his difference the
problem is anthem already controls that
destiny slash space as well as they're
trying to keep some narrative the
difference what Mass Effect is people
forget when two and three came out they
introduced a multiplayer mode that was
very successful it was like a co-op
almost horde mode
it had zoo let's keep it real you get
you could buy those boxes and you know
totem they've got their revenue stream
already there's really no need and I
feel like that markets changed since
then it has but you can't you cannot if
you want to bring Mass Effect back just
you have to you have to give people the
classic product it has to be my pain how
many - how many franchises if we said
that about and then the franchise made a
sequel and it wasn't like that well
that's right look at gears right gears
forward very safe because they had to
make sure that the coalition could make
a Gears game right um I think with Casey
coming back he made it clear before he
said it he said we're gonna give you the
mass effect that you want we're not it's
not gelled
reason I would say happens is because I
think it's cuz he's in that position
where he can dictate exactly that's his
baby he's not gonna let them bastardize
his baby that's not we know that that
game is coming we know that if they
brought him back it probably was a part
of his contract wait listen I'll come
back yes
you know I get a chance to have a crack
at my game letting my game go out how
it's supposed to go out I'm opposed to
this limp dog then you know limp to the
finish line that nobody really plays
right now so I will say this Mass Effect
coming back on a KC still has to be a
bigger beast than an old Mass Effect
right it still has to be different just
because that game is gonna be coming out
in a post cyberpunk world it's gonna be
coming out like it has to be it has to
be better has to be expanded it can't be
because we can say whatever Amida
Andromeda is and drama to follow that
formula just in a very boring way it
wasn't but the formula was there right
would it be fair to say because they
missed their opportunity in this gin and
trying to reboot it again next-gen that
it might have done too much damage to
the brand
I mean I'll let Bull Manson in on
jumping well look I mean you got one you
had one mass effect all generation and
it's received really poorly do you think
they'll be able to survive another one
next generation I just want to just
throw my two cents in for that because
here's the thing right now it's all
hands on deck to get anthem out and the
anthem do the do the the real grunt work
for them what they're going to you know
you got to remember Dragon Age and and
Mass Effect are probably going to be
funded by the success of anthem so you
may not listen you're not gonna see a
Mass Effect come out in 2020 because
you're gonna be talking about expansion
and that nature this is gonna be a
next-gen title for sure but what I'm
saying is that I if if they're if they
want to reinvigorate the love and the
fire for this franchise and
HD 4k HD are lovely package of the three
games that are most listen those three
games are probably some of the most
revered titles on the Xbox 360 they will
make a mint so again they have something
he said that we have some secret things
that were not ready to talk about it
right now that's really room oh that
that's probably that that that that
triple pact that we want I don't think
it's a Mass Effect for this generation
I completely agree all I'm saying is I
wouldn't be surprised if anthem was such
a hit and they made more money off
anthem in three years than they made off
Mass Effect the entire time and it's
been around but they just put everything
on the back burner and focus nothing but
on anthem um I listen I hear what you're
going with this all I'm gonna disagree
all I'm gonna say is that I grew a bone
we may not see mass effect still for a
while they're still working it mate is
it may not be ready for any twenty20
type of release the anthem is what they
were working on right now all eggs is in
the basket with Anthony I get that
weight but I do agree with boo one thing
you do is you let a franchise go away
for a while and then you bring out like
that's what like start the law bill
still wants that while starting back
with compatibility games don't come yet
because it's a lot of these publishers
that say hey we know we can give it to
you guys but we want to line it up yes
that's how you market so let's say
anthem does this well for all this
generation it started a new generation
starts the next generation of consoles
you know maybe they come out with
another game and Dan it's like all of a
sudden now we get the Mass Effect
package and then they just roll it out
with so you get the you know the 4k 60
all three games that is that is a cult
classic series you don't understand like
the Mass Effect fan base or ravenous and
they've been one it's like this isn't
easy money they sitting on right now
that they could drop on people go crazy
and that's how you get the love back
Mass Effect feel good feel good and then
you start lining up the marketing for
the new one right and that's how you get
the ballroom so that's why I think this
is a ways off but it was just happy for
me personally to see him talk about
because the scared fear as Mass Effect
means was when
drama to drop it was like that's it it's
under everybody's whirring five we're
like yo if they ant them flops or
whatever flops the neck it's over so
there's a little positive stuff I know
it's a little thing doesn't count I
think there's a good chance of antha
floss Bioware goes on there is no doubt
King anybody else on this time before we
roll out of here now right so let's get
this new ILP poll for the week all right
with the continued financial success of
Nintendo's mini consoles the NES SNES
you automate think this will negatively
affect the success of the Nintendo
switch moving forward answers are a yes
switch is already on the decline since
2017 be no no switch software still
dominates MPD or C I don't care until
they get a real online service Lord boom
stick people find you what you have
going on well first let me just say this
honestly and I'm not I'm not being a
kiss-ass here I'm being straight up this
is probably one of the best shows I've
ever been on
I mean serious like that you know what
it is when you get a group of guys who
just love gaming and you get around you
talk I felt like I was hanging in your
crib we're just watching some awesome
old and NCW you know I'm saying WCW NWO
joy felt like so I that that's amazing
and second of all it's listen guys it's
a real honor for me to be here I mean
like I said we've talked privately about
coming on the show and it's just
sometimes we couldn't get the right day
someone was always doing something but
just this was great listen all I say is
this if you're interested about
following a dude that has been in the
gaming bit
for 40-plus years and gives an honest
opinion I don't worship a piece of
plastic I support them okay and my
videos if you look at my channel there's
nothing and I mean not even one of them
that has clickbait okay
they are straight-up honest from the get
it - if I get two views then I got two
views but if I get a thousand views that
means I did something right
preach okay so he said on the exact
officer I mean listen I I love doing
this I love this community I love
branching out and meeting new people I
think that's really what the what makes
this community so amazing is that
everyone is willing to give each other a
hand and I think that's important okay
again I'm an old school cat we all know
that go check out my youtube channel
double-barrel gaming on youtube if you
want to laughs okay well I go live
Tuesday mornings at 10:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time
that's the boom pop up podcast where the
subject matter is usually old school
stuff yeah a lot of old school stuff
goes up on there I actually just did arm
what actually last week as a matter of
fact Mass Effect Andromeda why it failed
I failed so that was that was a good one
and then if you want to check me in one
check out the breakfast with boom Friday
mornings 10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time I have my guess range it's usually
at a curiosity what do you eat at
breakfast of them I have my oatmeal
because I'm coming from the gym that's
me so I'll have my oatmeal right before
breakfast with boom and maybe I'll have
a couple of bottles of water but I don't
really eat nurses you don't eat there
and I feel like that's that's false
advertising well I'm drinking water I
don't know if that cast is food but you
have to show it's it's I'm there I'm the
host but I have a rotating chair chairs
it's either three to five people it's
always new every week it's never the
same person because like I said
the more people I can promote the better
I feel as a hope same here man I do
weekly videos they're sporadic because I
obviously like now news is a little a
little you know there's not much really
going on so you kind of really gotta put
it together to get some news out there
but I do try to put out at least one
video per day and it's not quick baby
man that's all it's all legitimate how I
am right now on the air is how I am in
real life this is not a persona for this
is not an act this is the real me and I
was like I said dude I appreciate all
the support I'm a few subs away from
1200 let's go get him then we got to get
you did big deal and last night when I
was looking through my stuff because I
don't look at the numbers every day cuz
that's crazy but I I surpassed 100,000
views in eight months
wow that is that's bananas because like
I said I mean I I didn't even realize I
was gonna get a hundred subs let alone
nearly twelve hundred so again thank you
a big shout-out to the community has
supported me big shout-out to everybody
on this panel listen we definitely got a
game together because the real yeah
absolutely well mine is simple mr. King
getting with you know King he's doing
whatever Kings doing but once again guys
it was it was a real honor and a
pleasure to be here thank you so much
for the invite you all welcome always
pleasure to have you in Roman Lords it
long overdue positive in the community
real stand-up guy from New York - yo I
got a show lover Daisy bear we had to do
it but like I said love what you're
doing please support like I said
double-barrel gaming you can find like I
said on these two shows as well as
crossfire and where I got a chance to
interact them for the first time and I
was like yeah absolutely man
shout out to those guys because I
wouldn't have got a chance to interact
with mobile I mean really good do so
salute to him Lord addict
what can the fine people find you what
you got going on you can find me on
Twitter
Lord addict IOP definitely follow me on
there I'm actually coming close to a
thousand followers oh let's go let's get
low active subs man gaming addict let's
go I'll be I'll be streaming I'm
probably gonna stream on the IOP twitch
yeah it's move on darks that's phase
three okay yeah yeah we got to see I'm
trying to convince him to play and the
hardest difficulty but I'm not winning
in that he wants to play it on easy but
that's not happening probably point on
like the hard to the one low below that
she will see that see how that goes i
have no calls medium service called
medium but i see how that goes to see
I'm hoping that can beat it no doubt
Lord
solve what do you have going on and what
can I find people find you not online
this week I'm gonna do it I'm not gonna
be retweeting everything that my Lords
put up and Xbox Live PSN of bx auburn
damn big shout out to boomstick you know
i love it when the old man come on
because that's that's all talk Lord King
we're gonna find people find you what do
you have going on
you can fire me or destiny you guys are
is it is so beautiful to see the
community come together in such a form
in a fashion Facebook Instagram and
Twitter is all let Facebook is for
promotional as the community twitter is
for day-to-day getting at each other
talking finding out what's going on
business moves gaming news stuff like
that you can really see us interact in
there and Instagram is for the behind
the scenes and as this shows the stuff
that you really want to see what goes on
what else what's really happening
what they like what they eat what's
weird stuff is happening is there you
can check out
but I'm loving everything that's going
on I'm loving the fact that we bring in
pure gaming that the whole fundamental
back the movement um mr. boomstick
listen I love the whole narrative the
narrative is good guy gives back who
also games and it's it's beautiful
because this is what we're talking about
this is what we're promoting and and if
any platform can elevate that so it can
be visualized to other people so they
can see it they don't have to cater to
the lowest denominator to get news and
to get clicks the Mainers being
successful with being good so let's not
make good a bad thing I tell you all the
time if I'm playing jump in there I
don't wait I don't care what's know if
we're doing a radio we're doing
something we a space come on then man we
have no problem with it
[Laughter]
we all love the same mistress we all
loved the same mistress and she's been
very good to us so I want us to keep
enjoying this situation this video games
because coming from dot pixels to what
we have now is insane is magic better
yeah man like I said that tremendous
show again lord King preach preaching
the gospel of the Lord so much
appreciating like I said little boom
doing the positive things out here again
hit that like subscribe YouTube on all
the inner circle neat Network media as
well as the iron Lord podcast channel
shout out the Lord carbide to on the
audio will try to get that up later
tonight for an mp3 card on iTunes and
SoundCloud and those links will be in
description when he gets that on the IOP
channel flashpoint 25 is up with Yvonne
says deep-diving we went very deep on
Friday mornings going in with our
nitu what's been going on all the latest
changes getting ready for forsaking we
good job yeah we had a lot of fun with
this this may be the time to come back
if you're on offense you want to learn
what has changed please listen the
flashpoint we worked very hard on it
support me and my brethren and of course
Lord King combat talk when we got
another one coming on ILP we got another
one coming up in September actually we
have a couple that September but we have
some really good worthy fights that need
to be talked about and sometimes you
have Shawn Porter versus Danny Garcia
you have triple G versus Canelo and I
believe we have Joshua versus Povetkin
now I don't normally cover Joshua
because I think he has a heart of a
mustard seed because I believe Povetkin
is gonna play spoiler with the wilder
Joshua fight you know you have Joshua I
mean while the verse is fury that
they're trying to lock down but that's
not a September I trust me combat talk
is coming back what a fury in September
and it is a ton of really good fight
said you should be interested in no just
don't take you know to heart that this
weekend nothing was reported on
everything sucked this weekend all right
each meal boxing man no actually HBO
boxing was the the the the bully going
after tomato can where the tomato can
actually tore him up alright so the dead
be careful what you cherry-pick you're
gonna get knocked out cherry picking all
right and you had two bombs on pbc which
was on Fox that is a subsidiaries it was
a showtime situation so we showed that
come we'd build it out hey man what's up
everybody
like I said anybody got anything else
and again shots or pictures that's all
in the back what's up you said yet
anything yeah real quick I just wanted
we forgot to mention this a big shout
out to our brethren Lord SWAT ILP oh
right on your impending nuptials
the realm rejoices you guys have said
astok I got to meet you guys two years
ago it's great that you guys are taking
that next step in your relationship so
the realm rejoices dilly dilly dilly
dilly shout-out to the lord smartly
tying the knot officially a lord in the
lady heaven it's fantastic we all knew
it was happening
fantastic there's good individuals great
gamers we had the pleasure of going to
e3 with them was what two years ago as
was I was there it's so much fun and
like I said so talented one of the
originators of ILP as well as the logo
we got again with props and dumb as far
as pan that she's just tremendous
tremendous game a tremendous writer and
it's good to see them on their journey
it's ILP approved the matrimony houses
come though some dope statues you got
there right I'm telling you right now oh
you gonna notice but I will show you a
Hulkbuster I got about 10 years ago it
is C this is the type of stuff you'll
find on the IOP Instagram you know
please support us on Instagram we've got
a lot of pictures up there a lot of us
interacting at shows all that cool stuff
Becky got a shot it we got together and
just a forewarning when football season
is approaching it would be approached by
probably September so that's when we
move back to 11 we'll give you guys the
heads up just what you know at and then
28 2019 starts and eventually we get
back to 1 p.m. again just giving you a
lot of heads up on what's happening so
if everybody got anything else to say
we're gonna get out of here everybody
enjoy your Sunday and peace
you
[Music]